[Música]
en France 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy Valentina
Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión vamos a
iniciar en San José la capital
costarricense donde tuvo lugar el whites
con el congreso más grande del mundo
sobre Derechos Humanos en la era digital
con la participación de unos 175 países
uno de los temas clave de discusión fue
el intercambio de datos biométricos de
migrantes y otras personas en movimiento
entre Estados Unidos y Naciones
centroamericanas la reglamentación en
torno a la recolección y manejo de
dichos datos es poco transparente y
organizaciones alertan que existen
riesgos de privacidad para los migrantes
porque con esta vigilancia hay temor
sobre un posible perfilamiento racial
que puede llegar a impactar en las
decisiones de las autoridades
migratorias elver Rivas colaborador de
France 24 estuvo en el evento y conversó
con algunos expertos
Estados Unidos cuenta actualmente con
algunos con acuerdos con algunos de los
países de la región entre ellos por
ejemplo México
Guatemala Honduras El Salvador que
permite el intercambio internacional o
transfronterizo de datos biométricos
estos datos cuando mezclamos el lenguaje
digamos de estos acuerdos con las
tecnologías que están en terreno
incluido en lo que ahora se tiende a
llamar como fronteras inteligentes se
logra hacer un seguimiento bastante
preciso de las personas migrantes a
través de estos datos que son únicos de
cada persona por qué Porque los sistemas
las tecnologías
que se comparten esta información son
interoperables y son accesibles a
múltiples autoridades a lo largo del
camino desde 2013 México cuenta con un
memorando de cooperación no vinculante
con Estados Unidos mientras que
Guatemala Honduras y El Salvador
firmaron un acuerdo similar en 2014
todos esos pactos están enmarcados
dentro del objetivo de mejorar la
seguridad Nacional de los países Pero
según las organizaciones estos acuerdos
han abierto la puerta a la
criminalización la discriminación y la
vigilancia de una población que muchas
veces están en situación vulnerable Cómo
puede verse impactada una persona
migrante a partir de la recolección de
sus datos biométricos y otros datos
personales puede por ejemplo se le puede
negar la entrada a un país puede ser
deportada puede ser separada de su
familia así que finalmente realmente se
está afectando de manera arbitraria en
algunas ocasiones el destino migratorio
a esta persona y las posibilidades de
llegar a tener una mejor vida
cabe aclarar que no se trata solo de una
preocupación en la región de hecho es
uno de los temas clave de discusión
dentro de la Unión Europea con su
proyecto de ley o ley preliminar sobre
La regulación de la Inteligencia
artificial el 14 de junio el parlamento
europeo se opuso a la utilización de
sistemas de identificación biométrica en
tiempo real en espacios públicos pero
abrieron la puerta poder utilizarlos con
autorización judicial para perseguir
delitos graves según amnistía
internacional es preocupante que el
parlamento europeo no haya respetado los
Derechos Humanos cuando los sistemas de
Inteligencia artificial afectan a las
personas migrantes refugiadas y
solicitantes de asilo el parlamento no
prohibió los sistemas discriminatorios
de elaboración de perfiles y evaluación
de riesgos ni los sistemas de previsión
utilizados para restringir prohibir y
evitar los movimientos fronterizos
la comisión y el consejo europeos ya
discuten el que será el texto definitivo
sobre la ley de Inteligencia artificial
y justamente continuamos hablando de
esta tecnología y vamos a Madrid el
español es la segunda lengua más hablada
del planeta sin embargo los avances
tecnológicos tienen un importante sesgo
lingüístico hacia el inglés Pues porque
la mayoría de información en la que se
basan o de la que se nutren está
redactada en ese idioma la Inteligencia
artificial no escapa este sesgo Y es que
los modelos de lenguaje que conocemos
como han sido entrenados con datos
disponibles en la web que están en un
80% en inglés a la hora de crear
contenido en español en muchos casos se
usan modelos genéricos que han sido
entrenados en inglés y luego se traducen
esta traducción puede hacer que se
pierda calidad es por ello que varias
empresas están apostando por entrenar
estos modelos de lenguaje que nutren a
la Inteligencia artificial directamente
en español para así optimizar los
resultados cuando se interactúe con ella
en este idioma una de esas empresas es
Brain basada en Madrid donde nuestra
corresponsal barina Colorado pudo
entrevistar a sus fundadora Elena
González blanco
aquí hay un punto que no solamente es
lingüístico sino de la tradición
cultural que lleva asociada al lenguaje
que es la parte más bonita de todo esto
Si tú entrenas un modelo con tu
literatura con tu historia con tus
costumbres y con tus formas de
interpretar cierto tipo de palabras en
un contexto pues al final te das cuenta
de que el carácter español en la forma
de cómo emplea una ironía o cómo cierta
frase puede ser percibida con un sentido
distinto dependiendo de cómo sea el
contexto conversacional pues es muy
diferente y no se puede traducir este
entrenamiento tiene que incluir la
multitud de variantes del español que
existen desde el español de México al de
chile pasando por el de España estas
diferencias dentro del mismo idioma
están involucrados en textos sencillos o
en la música uno de los ámbitos más
desafiantes para la Inteligencia
artificial González blanco doctor en
filología se interesó por este aspecto y
lideró el desarrollo de lyrics el primer
recomendador de música en castellano
basado en el significado de las letras y
en la melodía que utiliza Inteligencia
artificial para incluir canciones en
listas de reproducción aquí de nuevo la
riqueza del español supuso una
dificultad más O sea palabras como
papasito mamasita o baby no tiene nada
que ver en Latinoamérica con España
entonces este tipo de cuestiones no las
puedes comparar utilizando la misma
tecnología porque incluso nosotros el
recomendador de música nos fallaba
bastante cuando intentábamos mezclar y
de hecho tuvimos que hacer una parte que
es clasificar todas las variantes por
variantes lingüísticas también dentro de
la propia geografía de donde venía la
canción Porque nos hacía cosas rarísimas
según la experta lo que hace falta es
más entrenamiento de la Inteligencia
artificial en las distintas variantes
del español y más interacción con un
público hispanohablante que introduzca
sus localismos para que no siempre esté
expuesta a un español estandarizado así
llegamos al final de este espacio a
ustedes gracias por su sintonía
[Música]